[Music]
in less than a week before president
trump leaves office he has earned the
distinction
of being the only president who has been
impeached twice
the impeachment story is splashed across
newspapers front pages nationwide it's a
headline everywhere
after the house accused the president of
incitement insurrection
10 republicans broke ranks joining all
the democrats to vote
to vote yes no house republicans voted
to impeach the president
last time house speaker nancy pelosi has
signaled she will send the article of
impeachment to the senate for trial
quickly although it has not arrived as
of this morning nancy cordes covered
yesterday's historic debate
on capitol hill nancy good morning to
you what happens now
well tony the senate republican leader
mitch mcconnell says he will not
bring the senate back early for a trial
it's
expected to return midweek next week
which means that that phase
will only get underway in earnest once
president trump has left office
and democrats have taken control of the
senate it would take a two-thirds
majority in the senate
to convict president trump and prevent
him from
ever running again in a letter to his
republican colleagues wednesday
afternoon
leader mcconnell said i have not made a
final decision on how i will vote
and i intend to listen to the legal
arguments when they are presented to the
senate
those in favor say aye those arguments
will likely sound a lot like what we
heard in the house
as members voted to impeach president
trump in the same chamber where they
cowered in fear one week ago there must
be consequences for last week's
treason and sedition the attack on the
capital
and the congress was the single most
depraved
betrayal of the u.s constitution ever
committed by a president
all the democrats voted to impeach plus
10 republicans
including a party leader a new member a
staunch conservative
and moderates like washington state's
dan newhouse
there was a domestic threat at the door
of the capitol
and he did nothing to stop it afterwards
house speaker nancy pelosi
spoke at the lectern that had been
recovered after a rioter
swiped it last week the house
demonstrated that no one is above the
law
not even the president of the united
states we're going to walk down
to the capitol the sole article of
impeachment
accuses the president of inciting an
insurrection last wednesday
that killed five people and put his own
vice president in harm's way
the president bears responsibility for
wednesday's attack on congress by mob
rioters
he should have immediately denounced the
mob republican leader kevin mccarthy
agreed the president was to blame but
i believe impeaching the president in
such a short time frame
would be a mistake others argued mr
trump didn't deserve the punishment
if we impeached every politician who
gave a fiery speech to a crowd of
partisans
this capital would be deserted what's
being debated
is whether with 167 hours left until he
leaves office
is he a clear and present danger and he
clearly
isn't resolution is adopted they were
outnumbered and now the resolution goes
to the senate
for a trial that could start late next
week
in a statement after the vote
president-elect biden
said that he hopes the senate will carry
out its impeachment responsibilities
while also working on the other urgent
business of this nation
by urgent business he means confirming
his cabinet and addressing his
agenda but at best the senate will only
be able to devote
half days to that duty the other half of
the day it will be working on this
trial something that could last a couple
of weeks anthony
nancy thank you